tout de suite l'invité de parler direct
et nous recevons ce matin mickaël stang
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes journaliste vous cosigné avec
le chanteur et écrivain gaël faye un
film documentaire intitulé rouanda le
silence des mots on y découvre trois
femmes marie jeanne compte c'est ça et
prisca trois femmes qui ont accepté pour
la première fois de témoigner devant une
caméra des témoignages précieux poignant
violent également ce sont des survivants
du génocide perpétré contre les tutsis
en 1994 au rwanda elle raconte ce
génocide ce moment qu'elles ont vécu
elle dénonce également d'autres crimes
il s'agit de viol qu'elle aurait subi de
la part de soldats français des soldats
qui étaient à l'époque censé les
protéger je vous propose de regarder un
extrait de votre documentaire on en
parle juste après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
català éclat
ni dzeko
marozia maroc
émane et saint clar la malle et la mesa
von arx au
balo s'est humanisé
radu marinas
et savannah au
balo
[Musique]
le gard
ça c'est le début de votre documentaire
on voit donc ces femmes dans ce but dans
ce bus qui va les mener on saura après
un dans ces deux camps où elles ont tant
souffert on sent la force mais aussi la
dignité de ces femmes quand vous avez
tourné ces images vous vous ai dit
souvent quand on tourne on se dit c'est
ça ça c'est une évidence c'est comme ça
qu'on va qu'on va débuter vous vouliez
aussi redonné peut-être un peu
d'humanité en fait à toute cette horreur
toutes ces horreurs qu'elle répond ce
qu'on voulait surtout c'est qu'elle
puisse être ensemble pour retourner sur
les lieux de calvaire c'est à dire ces
deux camps de réfugiés le camp de
nyarushishi et le camp de mourant be
dans le sud du pays dans le sud du
rwanda
là où en effet elles ont été violées par
des soldats français mais pas uniquement
puisque elles ont traversé tout le
génocide dans cette région là l'idée en
effet c'était de l'est de les réunir
dans un bus pour partir avec elle nous
avons pas suggéré en fait de lait de
partir avec elle c'est une des femmes
qui nous a demandé au moment où lui
proposait de de nous expliquer son récit
sont et de s'entretient avec elle elle
nous a proposé de retourner sur les
lieux et à ce moment là on s'est dit
alors on va proposer aux autres femmes
aussi de retourner sur ses lui elles ont
toutes accepté et ce qui est très
important et dans cet extrait c'est que
c'est parce qu'elles sont ensemble
qu'elles vont en quelque sorte en
pèlerinage si je puis dire sur le lieu
de ce calvaire il ya ce moment de
communion justement ce champ oui ces
chants religieux ce sont des femmes
religieuses en tout cas droit d'entrée
de 3 sur les quatre qui étaient avec
nous sont très pieuse et et c'est vrai
que dans tout ce voyage qui a duré
plusieurs jours puisqu'on s'est arrêtée
à plusieurs endroits elles ont beaucoup
chanté et chanter c'est aussi un moment
de communion bien sûr ça a été difficile
de les de les convaincre comment est-ce
qu'elles ont trouvé cette force pour
témoigner on a mis plusieurs mois alors
expliquer et à essayer de trouver une
confiance entre entre elle et nous pour
qu'elle accepte de témoigner à visage
découvert elle avait déjà parlé dans
différents articles de presse mais
s'était jamais exprimé devant une caméra
évidemment la force de l'image et plus
et plus dures et plus compliqué pour
pour elle il a fallu des moines
de discussions le discussions pour leur
expliquer vraiment que le projet c'était
un projet au long cours c'est un projet
où on allait arriver gaël et moi sur
place non pas pour leur voler en
quelques sortes le récit mais pour
vraiment leur expliquer que on était là
pour partager un moment avec elle et
pour qu'elle puisse avoir confiance à
avoir confiance et surtout parlé de
manière vraiment libre de ce qu'elle
avait vécu on va écouter un nouvel
extrait un extrait de lors de leur
témoignage je pars et je vous faire un
geste après
[Musique]
quelques tournées non content
wadia au studio radio marca benoît hamon
france à ningbo dooya casillas au micro
série qu'on pouvait la cour avant
d'aller voir mon comme les haïtiens et
les bagues et leucate et ôte tout tout
alors là on les entend témoigner
notamment marie jeanne sur ce qui se
passait dans ce fameux camp alors elle
elle était dans le camp de nina rouchy
où il y avait donc ces soldats français
également qui était donc censé les
protéger de par l'opération turquoise
elle raconte ses viols pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles ont décidé de sortir du silence
tout d'abord c'est un silence qui est
qui pour elle existe depuis plus de 18
ans c'est la première fois qu'elles ont
témoigné qu'elles ont que les plaintes
ont été recueillis parce qu'il faut bien
savoir que si nous nous avons fait ce
documentaire c'est parce qu'elle avait
porté plainte auprès de la justice
française une plainte contre x expo
revial pour viol et que cette plainte a
été enregistrée en 2004 puis 2009 puis
2012 puisque elles sont six à s'être
plaint et en a trois dans votre
exactement et ce qui est important c'est
que depuis 2004 la ces plaintes ont été
reçues par la justice française elles
ont été entendues par des juges par des
à l oms les avocates mais l'instruction
qui est en cours depuis 2010 elle est
tout pour moi c'est à dire que il se
passe rien c'est à dire que de temps en
temps il ya quelques éléments qui sont
apportées au dossier mais il n'ya il
n'ya il n'ya rien parce que tout
simplement les parties civiles les
avocats qui défendent ces femmes ont
demandé à l'armée de laure
leur donner un trombinoscope des hommes
qui étaient présents des hommes des
soldats français qui étaient présents
sur ce camp en 1994 et l'armée refuse de
donner un trombinoscope en expliquant
qu'il n'y a pas de trombinoscope et
qu'il n'y a pas de de nom et de photos
de ces hommes là donc vous voyez ce
silence dont vous que vous évoquez il
existe depuis des années des années
alors pourquoi elles ont accepté
maintenant est ce qu'il ya une
temporalité particulière mais manuel
mâcon et s'est rendu à kigali à il ya un
an il ya
les relations exactement les relations
sont meilleures entre entre nos deux
pays il ya eu le rapport du clair ce
rapport qui a été commandé ce rapport
d'historiens qui a été commandé par dans
l'adulte location par le président mais
en effet alors zim et violent alors dans
ce rapport dont l'apport du clair il y a
deux cents pages sur l'opération
turquoise donc cette opération militaire
qui a été mené avec l'aval de l'onu en
1994 il y a deux cents pages sur ces 200
pages n'y a pas une ligne sur les non
pas sur les viols ou sur les exactions
commises par les soldats français mais
même sur le comportement des soldats et
sur comment les soldats vivaient à
l'intérieur de ses camps dire que ces
soldats étaient dans deux camps de ceux
qui sont à 80 90 km du standing a
officié le camp est mort mais ils sont
ils sont intervenus sous mandat de l'onu
pour protéger les populations et
notamment les populations tutsi sauf que
d'après les témoignages qu'on a
recueilli que ce soit cela ou ceux
d'autres témoins bien sûr qu'il y avait
une protection militaire mais il ya eu
aussi des exactions commises et des
violences sexuelles donc voilà donc
c'est pour revenir cette question de
pourquoi elle elle témoigne aujourd'hui
c'est on leur en aura peut-être offert
la possibilité de le faire elles le font
aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas si leur effet yahia il ya
quatre cinq ou six ans en tout cas de
nous ce qu'on a voulu cesser recueillir
leurs témoignages et surtout pas réalisé
une enquête où on aurait pu faire
essayer de tenter de faire une enquête
et d'aller voir les militaires
d'interroger les militaires mais d'abord
on connaît la réponse des militaires
puisque moi je les avais moi-même
interrogé non il y a à 3 ans il n'y de
toute façon évidemment tout tout tout
viol ou toute exaction sur le camp mais
est donc avec gaël on s'était vraiment
dit allons juste recueillir la parole
donnant leur donnant leur avis un visage
ces femmes elles sont des fantômes
aujourd'hui il ya une peut-être aussi un
peu retrouvé vie grâce à ces témoignages
c'est une sorte de thérapie si je
pouvais revenir sur ces lieux des deux
d'en parler avec vous elles nous l'ont
dit et nous lourde ils nous l'ont dit
pour nous ça nous d'être ensemble de
témoigner ça nous redonne une certaine
dignité
vous pensez d'ailleurs parce que c'est
vrai que on aimerait ne jamais entendre
ce que l'on entend celles ci sur le sur
le génocide cette cruauté c'est violent
tout ça est absolument affreux mais
c'est une réalité une réalité qui ne
faut surtout pas oublier grâce à sept
moines y âge on oublie pas vous pensez
que d'une certaine manière aussi ce
documentaire peut peut-être faire
avancer un peu les choses notamment du
côté de la justice on sait jamais ça
c'est justement ce sera à la justice de
décider si elle apporte ce documentaire
comme une pièce en plus au dossier
judiciaire c'est pas à nous de décider
de ça je sais pas s'il va faire bouger
les lignes mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que il fallait que ces femmes
il fallait que ces femmes ont leur donne
un visage qu'elle existe et c'est pour
ça que dans le film on les voit
également dans leur quotidien et pas
uniquement dans leur dans leur
souffrance et dans le récit de leur
souffrance mais dans leur quotidien
marie jeanne qui est agricultrice aide
et au chant elle est filmée au chant
con c'est ça qui est masseuse dans un
hôtel elle est filmée pendant son
travail il ne fallait pas uniquement
s'attacher à ces femmes comme survivante
est rescapé mais aussi comme des femmes
qui s'inscrivent dans une fiente vidéo
ci-dessous exactement et dans la société
où vivent à laâyoune çà et là et qui
vivent avec tout ce passé toute sa
souffrance mais on a vu aussi alors dans
ce documentaire j'ai trouvé ça très très
touchant et très fort également les
filles de conseils de marie jeanne qui
viennent qui retourne avec elle dans ces
camps elles ont aussi leurs témoignages
sont aussi extrêmement poignant en sont
d'ailleurs la souffrance du poids de ce
passé qu'elle porte elle également en
tant que fille de survivantes du rwanda
mais elles savent que ce voyage valait
les d aider leur maman à guérir et
notamment et il ya tout ce témoignage je
veux pas tout révélé non plus parce
qu'il faut que les gens regardent ce
documentaire qui mérite vraiment d'être
regardée mais c'est important aussi
qu'il y ait ces jeunes filles qu'ils
soient là et qui témoigne justement à la
fin à la fin du documentaire et qui
parle de ce qu'elles vivent elles aussi
en tant qu' en tant qu' en tant que
fille c'était pas prévu au départ c'est
à dire que quand on est arrivés sur
place on avait on avait évidemment pris
contact depuis de longs mois comme je
voulais dit avec ces femmes on le savait
qu'elle avait des enfants bien entendu
mais quand on est arrivés en fait mary
jane et qu'on sait ça nous ont dit nos
filles partent avec nous donc on s'est
retrouvé en fait dans une configuration
extrêmement
bouleversante parce que on se retrouvait
avec deux générations la génération de
de ces rescapés du génocide des tutsi et
leurs enfants la fille de marie jeanne à
21 ans celle de conseiller à 23 ans
elles ont l'âge à peu près que leur mère
avait à l'époque du génocide moment où
elles ont été violées et faire ce voyage
avec elle évidemment donne une dimension
toute particulière à leur main à leur
mère c'est à dire que l elles vont sur
le lieu de leur mémoire le lieu de leur
calvaire pour la première fois et elles
vont montrer à leurs fils pour la
première fois là où elles ont vécu
d'abord de cette région là et puis là où
elles ont souffert et il ya en effet une
transmission qui se fait évidemment
obligatoirement à deux niveaux et de
niveau différent puisque la fille de
cons c'est ça elle n'est pas au courant
de 2,2 tout ce qu on sait tous que sa
mère a vécu en revanche la fille de
marie jeanne elle est au courant de tout
et on le voit dans le film c'est à dire
qu'on le voit que qu'il ya une volonté
de la part de la fille de cons c'est ça
qui s'appelle d'héliski de poser
beaucoup de questions en fait mais pas
sa mère elle pose beaucoup de questions
à la mer 2
de janelle qui est donc là l'autre la
fille de marie jeanne elle pose beaucoup
de questions à aux autres femmes mais
jamais à ça mais indirectement et dans
le film elle le dit à la fin dit je sais
pas à moi de poser des questions à ma
mère je sais qu'elle est pas prête et
quand on ne sera prête elle me
raconteras d'ailleurs qu'on sait ça
parle de cette honte aussi et ses
difficultés justement à s'exprimer vise
à vide de sa famille un dernier mot
rapidement sur le choix de ce titre le
silence des mots le silence des mots ça
dit beaucoup de choses d'abord c'est
c'est des mots c'est les mots de femmes
qu'on qui ont déposé plainte donc comme
je le disais en 2004 2009 et 2012 et
qu'on n'entend pas c'est ça le silence
des mots c'est le silence de démo pour
qu'elles ont beau raconter là c'est
l'indicible du génocide ont voté à
l'essai l'impossibilité on n'entend pas
cependant c'est l'impossibilité de ceux
de dire les choses et d'être entendus et
en plus de ça il se trouve que c'est le
nom du poème de gaël qui est le gall
failles qu'ils aient tort au milieu du
documentaire et qu' il a appelé le
silence des mots merci beaucoup michael
ce temps que je rappelle que votre
documentaire sera diffusé demain à 18h35
sur arte dans l'émission arte reportage
et j'annonce également de votre film a
été sélectionné au festival du figra le
festival international du grand
reportage d'actualité et du documentaire
de société dans la catégorie autrement
vu félicitations on espère que ça ira
encore plus loin je conseille encore une
fois à tout le monde d'aller voir ce
documentaire qui est très riche c'est
vrai que c'est difficile difficile
parfois à entendre tout ça mais il faut
l'entendre et il faut surtout pas
oublier ce qui s'est passé merci à vous
on retrouve sandrine gomes dans un
instant pour la suite de paradis
[Musique]